I broke my hand during John Adams I
punched the table so hard for a lot of
that I have my hand behind my back for a
lot of that it's easy to break your
hand private parts Kenny Pig vomit rush
in see he doesn't actually say the bad
thing himself he says it through a
character yeah well I don't do how about
you go to air 3:00 a.m. this morning
show us some characters okay Howard is a
really lovely guy everybody said he was
and then he turned out to be he was
really willing to do anything and she
was a great director Betty Thomas so she
let us play around and rehearse a lot
and get used to it and sort of improvise
a little bit you didn't really need to
because the script was so good well
either I'll tame him or I'll make him so
crazy he'll quit I felt terrible cuz I
didn't know it was a real guy until
Howard said to me at some point wow you
really nailed this guy did you like
listen to him and I was like this is a
real guy I was like I feel terrible now
I've made this guy look like the biggest
in the world and he's going to
have to go through his life now with
everybody being like Oh you're the
in that movie I talked to him
once some he was running a radio station
I had to do a interview on and they put
him on the air with me and I just like
hey how you doing it was terrible
terrible listen up
wnbc you hear that kind of lift
NBC
wnbc
wnbc I did this ridiculous accent when I
auditioned for it cuz I was just thought
I'll do every stupid Southern Sound I
can think of and then when I got the
part I said to Betty Thomas so I'll
learn a real accent she was like no do
that stupid accent that you were doing I
auditioned like five times she she saw a
lot of people over Phil Hoffman who who
was a friend of mine but I was really
obsessed with having one of those big
chunky college rings and I couldn't find
one and I remember getting the set the
first day and the prop woman came up to
me and she had to watch and stuff and
she said you know I felt like maybe you
would want one of these and she had a
college ring some reason she thought the
same thing and that whole performance is
that ring the ring is the whole thing
with that guy way my hands move the way
the guy thinks of himself is all in that
ring horrible guy yeah Horrible
character I hadn't done that much in a
film before that was definitely the
biggest thing that I'd ever done before
that I saw it was like NYPD Blue Man in
sleeping bag that's correct man in
sleeping bag I was a witness of a crime
I think my line was I didn't see
anything man you guys see anything going
on here last night no I didn't see
nothing they bring you in for a day and
you have three lines a lot of the time
you've never read the script they just
hand you this thing it'll change oh you
have a dog now or something you're like
okay or you have to be the bartender and
you have an insanely elaborate thing
with all these drinks and you're serving
everybody and you have some lines or you
have to go in and like break down in one
scene you're the person who freaks out
about their kid for a few lines in one
scene you know you just do whatever the
hell they tell you to do that's the
hardest stuff to do do always and I have
huge respect for people who do that cuz
I had to do it and it's it's not
easy sideways
miles we're drinking Mero oh no if
anybody orders Mero I'm leaving I am not
drinking any Mero okay okay
relax miles that script gave you
everything over and over and over and
over and over again just every time I
looked at that there was more and every
time we did it there was more he's such
a good writer and Jim Taylor that he
wrote it with it's all there you don't
really have to do a whole lot of work
you just got to stay out of the way and
just let it happen I remember I was very
specific about the beard I had I wanted
a beard like Ernest
Hemingways because I thought this guy
thinks he's Ernest Hemingway so I had a
very kind of crafted beard I was very
specific about the beard like a r early
beard put your glass down get some get
some air into it oxygenating it opens it
up it unlocks the Aromas the flavors
very important all the wine stuff was
very telling about the guy all the sort
of stuff those people do all that life
of like the smelling and all that stuff
and that kind of person who's that kind
of obsessive connoisseur about things
tells you something about what a
person's like go the glass
is it inevitable that he's going
to chog this bit it's coming You See It
Coming the thing about that that I
remember is that we only had maybe three
shirts cuz it was a very specific bad
polo shirt I was wearing so it had to
work oh yeah we managed to do it I think
and maybe two takes or something like
that maybe three come
off give me that bottle now that was
really hairy that Hill actually they had
stuntmen for a stunt doubles and the
stunt doubles had a hard time doing it
and Alexander was like we got to use the
actual guys but it it's much more steep
than it looks and it's all holes and
ruts and stones and dirt so Tom and I
like so it does really look like we're
like you know cuz it was hard to
run down that it was
harrowing Saving Private Ryan Sergeant
Hill is he here well I don't know maybe
with a mixed unit on the other side of
town uhhuh it's hard to get to the
Germans plant a hole in our Center a few
hours ago they cut us right in pill
what's his name again Ryan I've done
other sort of War things but that was
you know Innovative what he was doing in
that movie I don't know how many steady
cam operators there were at one time
operating and it was not terribly
structured necessarily it was very
Loosely blocked so that these guys were
running around catching whatever they
can almost like documentary filmmakers
and so they were all falling over and
banging into each other and hitting
because he didn't want it coordinated it
was a living scene you weren't cutting
all the time and stopping and resetting
then you're not worrying about hitting
marks you're not worrying about where
you know he wants to see the back of
your head and he wants to see you know
it's like you just forget about all that
and you just play it like it's a play
but it's even more than a play it's an
immersive place cuz those sets were
incredible John Adams actually had a lot
of that
too I mean I think I just fell cuz it
was incredibly slippery and muddy
everybody was falling all the time and I
think from that Spielberg started
developing this whole idea that the guy
his leg was messed up and he had a thing
in his shoe and he started just making
that up so he would come over and give
us the scenario and some lines I didn't
really have there was no part really it
was very very sketched in and so he must
have had some notion he wanted somebody
to fall through the wall so all those
German soldiers are exposed and I guess
he then just thought that's good I'll
have this guy fall through the wall sort
of hapless Soldier this guy who's just
exhausted in appless falling over I
suddenly had a character I didn't really
have a
character Big Fat Liar Marty
wolf excuse
me I need back up I really liked doing
physical things I didn't play a lot of
sports or anything I guess I wasn't very
competitive but I liked how theater and
acting could offer me a a way to do
crazy physical stuff and Sean Levy who
I'd known in college had seen me do a
lot of stuff like that I can't do a lot
of that stuff anymore cuz I'm getting
old and I injured myself a
[Music]
lot so I've always been physically
comfortable doing stuff like that in
front of people I mean there's obviously
an exhibitionist element to actors that
you kind of don't care or think about it
or you like it like love scenes are
harder to do than like physical shtick
like that I've Haven had to do a lot of
love scenes so it's all
[Music]
right really like at that point with
something like that he just was letting
me do so much ridiculous stuff and I
enjoy being big like that it's really
fun you know you don't get the
opportunity so much to just go over the
top like that and he knew I could it
just was I was having fun there was a
whole sort of facial hair thing I was
always trying to grow facial hair for
parts I remember I did Big Mama's house
and I grew a mustache with this cop and
they made me shave it and I was really
like why the do I have to shave
this they were really anti-facial hair
and I grew a beard for that Sean was
like they want you to lose the beard and
I was like I can't lose the
beard and he really fought for me and
they what he got was the Compromise of
just that chin beard which was great
actually cuz it's a stupid looking beard
I think it needed that cuz it actually
looks funnier like that with the orange
hair and the costumes the more over the
top and ridiculous the costumes we could
get the better Planet of the Apes
limbo oh the monkey the AP I was like
who the hell is
limbo it's like what the hell is limbo
was I in a picture called
[Music]
Limbo whaty are you trying to put me out
of
business oh these are the skankiest
scariest scuzziest humans I've ever seen
yes limbo the ape limbo the orang Tang I
was obsessed with the Planet of the Apes
movies as a kid and so the notion that I
could be in one of those was mindblowing
to me I didn't audition for that Tim
Burton came to me with that cuz I guess
he was like you look like a monkey so
I'll have you do this it was one of the
funnest things I've ever done and
working with Rick Baker was am amazing I
was covered head to toe shoulders and a
fat suit and my feet my agents were like
don't you think you should play a human
so they can see your face and I was like
if you tell them I want to play a human
in this I'll kill you all I was
like I'm going to play an ape I don't
need this
aggravation sell him to me are you crazy
he's wild the both wild then I'll buy
them
both oh no that that would be expensive
I had a very fast makeup artist named
Bill Corso is one of the best makeup
guys special effects makeup guys in the
world now and he was very fast I had the
most elaborate one and he did his in
about 2 and 1/ half hours most people
were about 4 hours in the chair and I
had these crazy giant teeth I asked them
to give me some teeth to practice with
cuz I wanted to be able to talk a lot of
people ADR it later CU they were just
you couldn't understand anybody
they these giant teeth but I really
wanted to learn how to talk with the
teeth in and it gave man if find any
kind of way of talking gives you
everything I didn't want to take it off
never I wanted to stay in it all the
time I loved it getting to do all that
monkey training and all that stuff the
physical stuff talk about everything was
there for me to do he made it feel not
like a gigantic huge Studio production
it felt very intimate and fun he was
just he wanted your ideas he wanted you
to just do weird stuff and he was very
sympathetic to the makeup and we'd have
to sit around for days sometimes and not
do anything that makeup makeup he'd have
his assistant bring people movies to
watch you know he cared about it it was
great Big Mama's House John I didn't
remember that name either you just want
us to sit around here picking ticks off
our ass I know nobody's tried to kill
you for the past couple of days the
stress must be overwhelming I was like
I'm going to be a cop so I'm going to
grow a mustache and I wanted to kind of
have like a not great mustache you know
he's a guy who can't really grow a great
mustache and they made me shave it I was
probably unconsciously drawing on those
kinds of guys in those kinds of movies
you know the kind of nerdy guy the nerdy
white guy without giving me a big
Southern welcome come on yeah come on
now whether straight man's supposed to
actually be funny or not is an
interesting question cuz like Abbott and
costell he's not funny Abbott but like
Laurel and Hardy the straight man's
funny I suppose you kind of try
different things you know and see just
what works but I mean there was not a
hell of a lot of a cap on that movie I
don't know that I was grounding Martin
Lawrence particularly I mean I mean I
think he was going to do whatever he
wanted to do but he was talk about
really crazy physical stuff and he was
he was amazing all the people in it were
really great Octavia Spencer's in that
movie she has a little part time for
what this time re's going to have a baby
I haven't talked about Big Mama's House
that much in my
life John Adams John
Adams the vice president would find we
agree on most matters if he could be
convinced that I mean what I
say so thought I failed in that task I
mean he had no teeth by middle age most
of those guys 30 they had no teeth we
didn't go that far cuz I was like
there's enough going on in this without
me having no teeth at all I think that
was a big part of it you know I had to
talk so much this feeling of this guy
that nobody was really listening to him
ever and at some point as it develops
After the Revolution really nobody's
listening to him and it's almost like
he's talking himself a lot of the time
you question my loyalty sir oh no Mr
Hamilton I question your sanity
now either you are stuck raving mad or I
am good day sir Hamilton well now he's
everybody's hero but he was a more
complicated figure when that thing was
being made all that stuff was taken from
letters and Diaries a lot of the
dialogue I really rip into them I rip
into a lot of people in that thing it's
fun you know especially that language
was really great that stuff really
sticks in your head and it comes out
rhythmically you know it's got music to
it and you can really feel it in your
body and in your mouth and it just fires
off at people and those you know they
talk those people talked with the end in
sight and they'd hit the end you know
it's really fun rhetorical language like
that does a lot of the work for
you American Splender Harvey
pear what kind of existence is this is
this all a work and stiff like you can
expect you going to suffer in silence
for the rest of your life I didn't
really know they didn't really know what
they were going to do with the animation
stuff they knew they wanted to do it
they just didn't really know until after
they had all the film footage together I
don't know if it's ahead of its time but
it was doing all this kind of reality
stuff right at the front of that stuff
happening so if you're the kind of
person looking for romance or escapism
or some fantasy figure to save the day
guess what you got the wrong movie
that's great okay so now you got four
pigs you ought to be able to patch one
together from there that was tricky too
because he was going to be in the movie
often times you get a part like that and
if people don't know what the like it
doesn't matter you can do whatever you
want you did kind of have to imitate him
well so that was a weird task I met him
right before we started filming I knew
who he was and I remembered him from
these Letterman appearances so I saw
some of that we were the comic book
version of those people so we had to be
a little exaggerated it was actually
really helpful to look at all the
different artist representations of him
in the comic books and I was like oh
that's kind of cool to see the way he
sits he had this funny kind of way of
moving and being in the world that was
very kind of animall likee the thwarted
of the guy that V vocal thing the weird
trap voice thing was actually a big part
of it this guy who's couldn't Express
all of his rage what do you mean you
mean you're dumping me for what how do
you think about SL how do you get into
playing the explosive
rage well if what starts to happen is
people want you to explode with rage I
don't necessarily want to explode with
rage all the time I get those parts how
that happens I don't really I don't know
that I can say I mean I suppose in some
way I'm unconsciously working myself up
into it I don't know you just go for it
you know you just see what happens and
sometimes I think as an actor I will
just blow it out as far as I can to just
go as far as I can first and then bring
it back although a lot of people like it
when you go as far as you can rage is a
really tricky thing to
play billions Chuck
Roads I was hoping not to go back to
Boyd but now we have to I'll need your
help
why would you already
decided before you told me the conned
piece we here at rhs Airlines know you
have many travel options and are
grateful that you have chosen to fly
with us thought the the kind of cat
Mouse like collar crime thing was
interesting I thought it was interesting
playing this kind of like dark Crusader
for justice guy and know this guy was in
his mind doing the right thing but kind
of going about it by any means and stuff
I he was he was a bit villainous a bit
and which was kind of cool but he was
also a good guy this very heady
intellectual sort of guy but he also has
this kind of animalistic thing about him
it's a lawyer you know and it's like I
don't think I'd ever played a lawyer
like that
before I am Italian so I mean I grew up
hearing Italian but I don't speak it so
I did have to learn it and do it as well
as I could it was some kind of weird
dialect too I think the whole thing was
weird dialect it was harrowing to do in
the moment cuz I was like am I going to
remember this is going to take forever
to shoot but it was okay I mean you know
that kind of burst of language is
fun The Illusionist inspector
o don't fool yourself that you can play
in their
game I've served on the edge of it
for many many years
and I can tell you with certainty
there's no trick they haven't
seen it's not worth it that was like a
kind of wish fulfillment thing too like
playing the Apes cuz it was a sort of
Sherlock Holmes world with sort of pipes
and black gloves and gasl and horses and
carriages which was something that I was
so excited to do and I got a German
accent and I had a slou black hat and
everything and I was a bit sort of
villainous but not really actually the
guy turns out to be a very sort of
decent guy just sort of doing his job
which was cool I liked that too about it
being in Prague the whole thing
immersive and like a whole world and
that kind of mystery thing with a weird
Supernatural thing I could have played
that character
forever the holdovers Paul
hunam need I remind you that it is not
my fault that you are stuck here do you
think I want to be baby you well in that
instance there was a lot of unconscious
memories I had many many people I'd
grown up with my father was an academic
and my mother taught high school and all
my grandparents were teachers and so I
grew up around a lot of that stuff and I
went to a school like that there were
some specific people that I had in mind
but I was familiar with the kind of
bookish world the cigarette smoke the
pipe smoking that kind of guy I was very
familiar with it's the script man I just
read it over and over again and it just
keeps giving you stuff it's the similar
kind of high toned language to like John
Adams or something like that I mean that
guy lives in another Century he doesn't
live in the Contemporary world that guy
Dr girtler says I don't always give
consideration to my audience ah and who
is Dr
girtler my
shrink has Dr gerler ever tried a good
swift kick in the ass talk to me about
the eyes I'm not I'm not at Liberty to
reveal yeah I'm not at Liberty to reveal
I think they want to maintain the
mystery of what the eyee was it works
which is really great and whatever we
were doing there definitely contributed
and helped with with the character that
was an external thing that definitely
made it work and James
beam all right all
right
[Music]
oh Presto Cherry's Jubilee people have
been calling the holdovers a cozy movie
that square with you squares with me I
don't think it squares with Alexander I
think Alexander for some reason takes
exception to it being called cozy and I
think he's just being a bit of a kudin I
think I think he knows exactly what
people are talking about I think he
likes it you know I mean it's in there
it's it's funny and it's heartbreaking
and there is inevitably something that
feels that way because of the snow and
the New England thing and stuff like
that and the Christmas thing there's
certainly enough spikiness in it to
counteract the Cozy in it but it's in
there you mentioned wanting to play a
bond villain if you were to build up a
bond villain for yourself how would you
do it wow that's an excellent question
I'd want an accent of some kind I
definitely want an accent it'd be nice
to have an animal with me of some kind
not necessarily a cat but something an
animal maybe not a parrot or something
you know something real I don't know an
accent of some kind I'd have to have
Furs would be great a guy's all in fur
coats and stuff like that be
great